[Musique]
toujours à ses côtés et toujours avec un
léger pas en arrière camilla désormais
reine consort des britanniques semblent
s'effacer en public pour laisser toute
la place à charles
camilla rose mary chain né en 1947 d'une
mère aristocrates et d'un père militaire
a longtemps eu le mauvais rôle celui
d'une briseuse de couple qui
en 1995 dans une entrevue choc très
critiquée de la bbc lady diana disait
qu'il y avait trois personnes dans son
mariage avec le prince charles en
référence à sa liaison avec camilla elle
même mariée elle était dans une position
très difficile surtout parce que la
presse a toujours dit des choses
mauvaises sur elle elle est une
maîtresse elle est vraiment quelque
chose que une femme qui a qui a volé ce
n'est pause
c'est en 1970 que camilla et charles se
seraient connus leur idylle aurait duré
trois ans puis charles a rejoint la
marine royale en 1973 camilla et
posaient militaires andrew parker bowles
avec qui elle a deux enfants thomas et
laura
en 1981 le mariage de charles et de
diana spencer a toutes les allures d'un
conte de fées mais ce n'est qu'une
façade rapidement la relation du prince
de galles avec camilla parker bowles
reprend faisant les choux gras des
tabloïds camilla divorce en 1995
et la fin tragique de diana la princesse
des coeurs en 1997 la condamne au
purgatoire quand on est fan de diana à
l'époque c'était difficile d'être fan de
camilla en même temps il a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour qu'on l'accès
d'abord parce que les méthaniers qui
aimait beaucoup la princesse fiona et
ensuite parce que même dans un pays une
bonne jambe les églises il n'aime pas
l'adultère pour faire oublier 20 années
de liaisons secrètes il fallait
restaurer l'image et la réputation de
camilla ses apparitions aux côtés du
prince charles ont été limités et elle
s'est impliqué dans des oeuvres
caritatives
tous les gens qui la rencontre dans les
différentes fonctions qu'elle a exercées
les visites qu'elle a fait une visite
officielle se rend compte qu'elle est
assez sain dans les années 2000 les fils
de charles et de diana l'acceptent elle
gagne même la confiance de la reine
elizabeth la reine a accepté camélat et
pas simplement accepté mais il semble
qu'ils étaient de bons amis il était
toujours ensemble
la reine a montré sa confiance en elle
forte de cet appui camilla exhibe devant
la presse sa bague de fiançailles
le couple convole en secondes noces en
2005 elles deviennent duchesse de
cornouailles mais son statut de reine
consort est incertain il a fallu
attendre le jubilé de platine de la
reine elizabeth pour qu'il en soit ainsi
quand
le roi charles iii la confirme dans son
titre ils vont désormais s'unir pour
servir la couronne d'angleterre ici est
mitraillée a traduit au canada montréal